the SCP Foundation is an organization  dedicated to locating and containing the  supernatural whether it's an object or  an entity or sometimes both such as  scp-035 also known as the possessive  mask this white dramatic face mask may  seem like a community theater prop but  it's actually a deadly monster with  mysterious Origins the possessive mask  is always searching for a host if placed  on the face of any living thing the  thing dies and their body Is Now piloted  by The Mask because the entity is highly  intelligent and malicious it's likely to  use its new body to wreck violent Havoc  one upside is that the power of the mass  degrades the host little by little the  bodies inhabited by The Mask will melt  into a kind of acidic black slime then  the possessive mask will be searching  for a new body to take over for your own  sake make sure it isn't yours